what advice would you give to young
people today
uh about life
about career how how they can have a job
how they can have an impact how they can
have a life they can be proud of so it
was kind of fun i got invited to give
the commencement speech back at the i
went to college for two semesters and
and dropped out and went on to do my
tech stuff
but they still wanted me to come back
and give a commencement speech and i
i've got that pinned on my twitter
account i still feel good about
everything that i said there
and
you know my my biggest point was that
the path for me might not be the path
for everyone and in fact the advice
the path that i took and even the advice
that i would give based on my experience
and learnings probably isn't the best
advice for everyone
because what i did was all about this
knowledge in depth it was about not just
having this surface level ability to
make things do what i want but to really
understand them through and through to
let me do the systems engineering work
and to sometimes find these
inefficiencies that can be bypassed
and
and that the whole world doesn't need
that you know most programmers don't or
engineers of any kind don't necessarily
need to do that they need to do a little
job that's been parceled out to them uh
be reliable let people depend on you do
quality work with all of that but
people that do have an inclination for
wanting to to know know things deeper
and learn things deeper
i'm you know the
there are just layers and layers of
things out there and it it's amazing
it's if you're the right person that is
excited about that
um the world's never been like this
before it's better than ever i mean
everything that was wonderful for me is
still there and there's whole new worlds
to explore on the different things that
you can do
and that i am
you know it's hard work embrace the
grind with it and understand as much as
you can and then be be prepared for
opportunities to present themselves
where you can't just say this is my goal
in life and just push at that i mean you
might be able to do that but you're
going to make more total progress if you
say i'm preparing myself with this broad
set of tools and then i'm being aware of
all the way things are changing as i
move through the world and as the whole
world changes around me and then looking
for opportunities to deploy the tools
that you've built and there's going to
be more and more of those types of
things there where
an awareness of what's happening where
the inefficiencies are what things can
be done what's possible versus what's
current practice and then finding those
areas where you can go and make an
adjustment and make something that may
affect millions or billions of people in
the world make it better when maybe from
your own example
how are you able to recognize this about
yourself that you saw the layers in in a
particular thing and you were drawn to
discovering deeper and deeper truths
about it is that something that was
obvious to you that you couldn't help or
is there some actions you had to take to
actually allow yourself to dig deep so
in the earliest days of personal
computers i remember the the reference
manuals and the very early ones even had
schematics of computers in the
background in the in the back of the
books as well as firmware listings and
things and i could look at that and at
that time when i was a younger teenager
i didn't understand a lot of that stuff
how the different things worked uh i was
pulling out the information that i could
get but i always wanted to know all of
that there was like kind of
magical information sitting down there
it's like the elder lore that some
graybeard wizard i you know is the
keeper of and so i always felt that pull
for wanting to know more wanting to
explore the
uh the mysterious areas there
and you know and that followed right in
through all the things that got the
value exploring the video cards leading
to the i'm you know the scrolling
advantages you know exploring some of
the academic papers and things learning
about bsp trees and the different things
that that i could do
um you know with those systems and just
the the huge larval phases going through
aerospace just reading
bookshelves full of books i mean again
that point where i have enough money i
can buy all the books i want it was
it was so valuable there where i was
terrible with my money when i was a kid
my mom thought i would always be broke
because you know i'd buy my comic books
and just be out of money but it was like
all the pizza i want all the diet coke i
want video games and then books books
and it didn't take that much as soon as
i was making 27k a year i i felt rich i
was just getting all the things that
that i wanted but
that sense of you know that's books have
always been magical to me and that was
one of the things that really made me
smile is uh andre had said he found when
he came over to my house he said he
found my library inspiring just
it was great to see you know i still
look he's kind of a younger guy i
sometimes wonder if younger people these
days have the same relationship with
books that i do where they were such a
cornerstone for me in so many ways but
that sense that yeah i always wanted to
know it all i know i can't and that was
like one of the last things i said you
can't know everything but you should
convince yourself that you can know
anything you know any one particular
thing
it was created and discovered by humans
you can learn it you can find out what
you need on there and you can learn it
deeply yeah you can drive a nail down
through whatever layer cake problem
space you've got and learn a cross
section there and not only can you have
an impact doing that you can just
you can attain happiness doing that
there's something so fulfilling about
becoming a craftsman of a thing yeah and
i don't want to tell people that look
this is a a good career move just you
know grit your teeth and you know and
bear it i
you know you want people
you want
and i do think it is possible sometimes
to find the joy in something like it
might not immediately appeal to you but
i had told people early on like in in
software times that i
you know it a lot of game developers are
in it just because they are so
passionate about games but i was always
really more flexible in what appealed to
me where i said i think i could be quite
engaged doing operating system work or
even database work i i would find the
interest in that i because i think most
things that are significant in the world
have a lot of layers and complexity to
them and a lot of opportunities hidden
within them
so that would probably be the most
important thing to encourage to people
is that i'm you can like weaponize
curiosity you can deploy your curiosity
to find i to kind of like make things
useful and valuable to you even if they
don't immediately appear that way
you